joining us here is a a friend and a
friend of the program and a hall of
famer literally and figuratively in his
own right uh bob costas how are you bob
i'm okay rich but more sad news 10
hall of famers in the last nine months
beginning with al k
line in april and of course when you
talk about hank aaron
it's insufficient to say that he's a
baseball hall of famer
it's even insufficient to say he's one
of the all-time
true inner circle greatest baseball
players all of that is true
but hank aaron transcended that hank
aaron is
an american hero and as you mentioned a
moment ago
a legitimate civil rights hero
it's often a cliche when people say well
he was great at this or that
but he was also a great person that
happens to be
true though cliches become cliches
because at least
occasionally they're true hank aaron was
a great
great baseball player he was also
a very decent man and i think a lot of
what he was able to
accomplish uh beyond baseball flowed
from the fact
that he was such an essentially good and
decent man
so let's uh how do you want to handle
this bob
you know because i mean because his his
the story of how
he broke into the bigs and then what he
became and then what he was
after playing and then the night of of
april 8
1974. um i guess let's let's get to that
i guess
through as the through line uh was it
was that night what were
your recollections of it and what
conversations might have you had
with with hank aaron about that night
where he broke the record
well you think about that night and
before i get into the contrast i want to
say that i just read
a very gracious statement that barry
bonds put out
upon learning of hank aaron's death so
we have to give barry
credit for that but now when you think
about
april 8th 1974
some of your audiences and old enough to
have witnessed it firsthand
i did i was a senior at syracuse
university um watched it on nbc that
night with kurt gowdy and joe garagiola
of course milo hamilton's radio call for
the braves and
scully typically great on dodger radio
are also frequently heard but i remember
kurt gowdy and joe garagiola
that night i was working already at wsyr
tv and radio
in syracuse while still going to classes
at the university so i was in the
newsroom
at wsyr tv and i remember
that even then and you couldn't take
this for granted in 1974.
there were two black staffers
there one was a cameraman and one was a
reporter
along with a couple of members of the
sports staff and
the new staff and everybody stopped no
matter what they were doing
aaron had one at-bat earlier in the game
i think and he walked
but each time he came up to bat
everything stopped
and everyone focused on the game you
have to remember that then
baseball was the true national pastime
you look at world series and all-star
game ratings then
as opposed to now and it was on nbc
not on espn no disrespect intended
it just had a different national impact
everyone was talking about it you didn't
have to know a sacrifice bunt from a
sacrifice fly
to know that this really mattered um and
give you an idea of what a different
time it was here's the the nine or ten
of us
decide collectively let's send henry
aaron a telegram
to congratulate him so we kind of
telegram i don't even know if western
union and telegrams exist anymore
we sent a telegram to the braves offices
in atlanta you used to think about this
right
henry aaron probably being congratulated
by everyone in baseball by presidents
and dignitaries
um hey is there a telegram in there from
bobby costas and then the guys at wwe
yeah
i'd
you contrast that with the knight that
bonds
statistically and statistically only
surpassed henry aaron barry bonds has
seven more home runs than henry aaron
that is a statistical fact what henry
aaron did
on april 8 1974 has a deeper meaning
and a deeper resonance and so you
contrast the ambivalence
that people felt about what happened in
2007
in san francisco against the deep
and abiding respect and appreciation
that the images of april 9
april 8th rather 1974 in atlanta call
forth you know things are
objectively factual statistically
factual
and then there's a matter of what it
means to people emotionally
what it means historically what it means
in legend
henry aaron had all that a thousand
times over that night and
throughout his career did you ever have
a conversation with him about the hate
mail
that he kept yes in his attic yes okay
um we we talked about it i it was an
honor to be able to say
not only that i covered and interviewed
hank aaron but that we were friends
um and he asked me to to emcee a few
events
charitable events that he was part of a
birthday celebration that president
clinton
attended and the temptations performed
at
um i guess sometime in the late 90s
because clinton was still
president so i knew henry pretty well
and we had this
conversation both privately and once on
the air
and my point to him was i just hope you
know
that even in the face of this stark
unvarnished racism that you faced and i
understand
why you would keep those letters because
he had explained it
many times he didn't want to forget what
it was
that he faced and one reality not the
only reality but one reality
of what america was at that time
and i might say parenthetically here
rich we thought that had been confined
to the deepest darkest corners i'd like
to think it
isn't something that we're going to be
living with
forever but we've seen in recent years
that that
that that dark element of american life
has not been extinguished it exists
and it's larger than we wanted to
believe it was
but it was right in henry aaron's face
as he approached babe ruth's record
but what i wanted the point i wanted to
make to him was i hope you knew then and
now
that millions and millions of white
americans
were also rooting for you not just black
america
a sizable portion of white america got
it
surpassing babe ruth's home run total
doesn't mean that babe ruth
wasn't an all-time great player and that
he doesn't matter anymore in baseball
history
he'll always matter here's the proof he
still does
babe ruth's name still resonates but
that
millions of white americans even then
not in retrospect but even then
had some understanding they couldn't
have a full understanding because they
didn't experience it directly
but some understanding of what it was
you faced
not just as a player but as a person and
great respect and admiration
for you triumphing not only on the field
but over all the societal pressures
that you face and his face softened
in a small smile and he said yes i
i understand that i've always understood
it and i understand it now
but that doesn't change the other
reality and of course he's right
you know these aren't realities that you
have to pick aside
they're both true one is a glorious and
triumphant reality
henry aaron's story and the other is an
ugly reality
what he had to face in addition to rival
pictures
and even today we see that in one way or
another
that that awful element of
american life has not been fully
extinguished
we still have to confront it bob cost is
here
uh on the rich eisen show and uh when
bonds broke the record he was there you
know he was there
he he took part in it he did not um
he did not uh i guess shy away from
uh from the moment wha what was his take
on all of that
uh with bonds now that we see his
statement today
rich it's a measure of just how classy
and gracious he was
that when the giants asked him to do it
in anticipation of
of bonds hitting 756 he agreed to do it
they stopped the game there's a
celebration in san francisco and then
all of a sudden on the jumbo
tron there appears henry aaron
with a very gracious message of
congratulations
to barry bonds and if hank was
annoyed or felt uh some affront
that his record was not only broken but
broken under the circumstances that it
was which we all understand
he was too gracious and too big
a man to ever say that to ever growls
about that publicly
and i think in many ways not just with
regard to the record
but with regard to his whole life his
career and his whole life
for a very very long time hank was very
comfortable with what he had achieved
the life that he led
and the way the vast vast majority of
the american public
viewed him so he didn't have to offer
any explanation
or any well yeah but i did this i did
that you never heard anything
like that from him uh what he did
both as a player and as a person spoke
for itself
and i think he had great peace of mind
about that
every year at cooperstown when the hall
of famers come back and it's such
a striking scene when you see all these
bold-faced names
on that stage in cooperstown and they're
all warmly greeted and the applause is
greater for the sandy colfaxes and
the willie mazes and some others and
understandably there's levels
of greatness but when henry was
introduced
in recent years the appreciation had a
different
tone to it uh there was just an abiding
respect and appreciation you could feel
it
in the way the crowd responded to him
and then
afterward at the gatherings uh in the
hall of fame
in the gallery where the hall of fame
plaques are henry would
sit especially in the later years of his
life he had trouble standing
and he would sit and he was such a
humble man none of this came
from him there was no bravado about him
but not only would fans and various
baseball people
but hall of fame players themselves
greatest of the great
would come to him as as if as if they
were
coming to a dignitary of some kind and
he would sit there and almost receive
them
and none of that came from any sense of
of
ego on his part but that's just the way
people felt about him to see
a ken griffey jr go toward him
with the deepest respect um i'm talking
to mr aaron now
no no one else i'm talking to mr aaron
now
that's what he that's the place he held
and it was a place he had earned
a few more minutes left with bob costas
here on the rich eisen show what do you
think the conversation
between hank aaron and joe morgan is
going to be like tonight
you think about that one
well you know they they knew each other
well
um i had great regard for both of them
happy to know that uh or to be able to
say that i was friends
with with both of them um
you know if if it happens that way
the way some people think it does and it
would be nice to think that it does
then it isn't just a conversation with
joe morgan or jackie robinson
it's a conversation with babe ruth you
know
it's a conversation with every great
player who ever played
uh if that's the way it plays out
yeah it it's amazing lasorda will be
there too right
i mean it's just um oh you're right it's
been a really tough year bob
it's been uh it's been a rough year for
for some living hall of famers who have
uh
who have left us well one one more
thought here sure um i think very often
we think of people defined by
uh the big public stage circumstances of
their lives
but how they respond to those
circumstances
is an outgrowth of who they were
to begin with i think of a conversation
i once had with arthur ashe
and i made what i thought was a good
point and he thought it was too
i said the way you carried yourself
arthur off with such grace
and class and dignity in part
was that the same thing as with jackie
robinson
who was a more combative person by
nature
than arthur ash was but you'll recall
that branch ricky
had the famous conversation with
robinson and said at least for the first
few years
you can't fight back you have to carry
yourself with great
reserve at this if this experiment is
going to work
and robinson knew as unfair as it was
that since all
eyes were on him any misstep would be
misinterpreted
and used against him and against the
cause
so arthur did you
understand that when you were the only
black
face at wimbledon on the court or
in the stands the only blackface there
was that part of why you felt an
obligation to carry yourself the way you
did
and he said you know what you're saying
is true
and i understood that it was true of
jackie robinson but the main reason
i was the way i was and am the way i am
was that when i was a kid if i wasn't my
father would have kicked my ass
[Laughter]
so whether it's arthur ashe or it's hank
aaron whomever you want to name
who you are in the big circumstances is
a product of who you were in the small
circumstances
bob you're the best uh uh you know uh
now that you have uh
placed that in perspective uh now i'm
thinking you know what's the
conversation with muhammad ali going to
be like right
and arthur and ash joining jackie
welcoming uh hank aaron and uh it's just
um
i'm getting emotional just thinking
about it bob i really am
and you and you know rich when people
say
and i hope this has been discredited
except in
other weird bubbles stick to sports
stick to sports
it hasn't always been african-american
players and athletes
but predominantly it has been why
because for the longest time sports
and some aspects of entertainment
were the places where black americans
were able to break through
first and command people's attention and
since sports is
basically a meritocracy it's hard to
deny
the greatness of someone who establishes
themselves
like muhammad ali did or arthur ashe or
hank aaron or
or whomever but this idea of stick to
sports
sports sometimes i'm not saying that
every pronouncement by every black
athlete
is automatically correct or
automatically to be agreed with
i don't believe that every everyone with
a twitter account is automatically
frederick douglas and nikes
but there is a long and proud history
of black athletes making a difference
and not only representing other black
americans
but forcing white americans
to focus on the legitimacy of the points
they were making
either making directly or or
symbolically
uh and hank aaron is very very near the
top
of that list he is an important american
not just an important baseball player
bob thank you so much um i knew
you were the first person i thought of
so thank you so much for taking the time
here
on on a friday at the last second and um
and let's chat down the road you'd be
well thank you rich take care the one
and only bob costas